my name is Daniel Eisenberg I'm a
professor of management practice at
Babson global in boston and i'm also the
founding executive director of the
babson and entrepreneurship ecosystem
project and what I do in life what we do
in life is to try to demonstrate that
it's possible do in a short period of
time within five years a very specific
location in the world move the needle of
entrepreneurship substantially from
point A to point B in such a way that it
becomes self-sustaining within that
given city state or country around the
world and so if you ask me what I would
like to be remembered for in the future
it's having successfully demonstrated
that's possible and then codifying it
and replicating it and scaling it if we
can succeed in doing that I think it
really will have a major impact on the
world because entrepreneurship of the
high-growth highly ambitious and picking
out of the box a contrarian variety the
kind of entrepreneurship that's based on
same value and creating value where
other people don't see it and don't
create it we think that that kind of
entrepreneurship has a major social and
economic impact on the world it creates
employment it creates satisfaction and
quality of life personal wealth wealth
for the environment so that's the reason
why you're worth totally devoted to
showing that it can be created by
impacting their what we call the
Entrepreneurship ecosystem in particular
regions around the world